et pour reparler nous sommes en direct
avec umberto giovanni médecins
chirurgiens à milan en italie on perd
tôt giovanni bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors qu'on vient de dire l'italie entre
dans une nouvelle phase avec l'extension
de ce pass sanitaire qui devient donc
obligatoire à tous les salariés une
mesure nécessaire selon vous pour
endiguer l'épidémie
moi je pense que les gros souci qui est
actuellement en italie c'est au niveau
de taux vaccination n'est très élevé est
arrivé avec leur lot regarde où je vis
on est à 80% des gens vaccinés et l'élan
on arrivait sur des dérives aussi des
prix à charge politique il faut savoir
aussi qu'il ya eu des élections
administratives et on est entre les
premier et deuxième tours c'est l'unique
élections en italie où il ya des tours
et
hélicos souci c'est qu'on prend
dominante histoire n'est pas forcément
il ya aussi un petit groupe e skog des
gens qui
sont nos bacs ce mais il a écrit aussi
des routiers et de travailler les ports
qui sont pas forcément déjà un petit
rien par exemple sous les routiers on
sait que 30 % des routiers c'est des
gens qui viennent et la biélorussie la
pologne et l'ukraine et si j'enlève ils
sont aussi parfois vacciner mais avec
des vaccins qui sont axées sur les prix
parce que ça peut être les spoutniks on
commence à mettre les sino backs et du
pot c'est vers la haye selon m une
possibilité de travailler et il faut
dire qu'ils apprennent à une 30% des
routiers qui traversent
la pénisule italienne
donc
mon premier but a quand même une grotte
au feuillage il fallait décider assez
malade et rendre obligatoire à la
vaccination alors que dans la façon dans
laquelle elle était défaite il faut
savoir quelle est la constitution
italienne les droits au travail il est
écrit dans la constitution
donc maintenant on empêche les gens qui
étaient partis qui n'ont rien n'était
pas vaccinée d'accéder au travail mais
le vaccin n'étant pas obligatoire c ces
résultats par ces gens là commune
chantage donc des points de vue
politique je pense qu'il le rêve pour
lui prendre la décision la dernière face
à blida corps et pas d'élire vous n'êtes
pas vacciné vous n'avez pas travaillé
mais les vaccins vous essayez libre
choix du vaccin c'est l'état qui doit
prendre la décision qui est pour les
maîtres du pays il faut vacciner tout le
monde c'est obligatoire et circuits ce
soir
dans cette vaccination obligatoire
vous vous êtes médecin
à milan comment ça se passe dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux est ce qu'aujourd'hui
tout le personnel soignant est vacciné
puis on sait que le vaccin est
obligatoire dans votre profession mais
ce qu'il ya encore une certaine
réticence
mais non j'ai l'exemple
effectifs de la clinique où ma fille des
acteurs du staff médical
malheureusement on allait chez nous on a
un jeune écologue stetrice y inquiets
qui n'est personne très brillant celle
ci la pointure enitalie sur tout ce qui
est habile homme un virus élu depuis
aujourd'hui il fait plus travailler la
crise parce que lui il ne voulait pas se
faire vacciner avec les vaccins les
redire là il attendait les vaccins novax
des partir d'aujourd'hui il faut les qui
s'efface tester tous les 48 heures pour
détenir travail de lacnic ans sinon qu
est qu il permettrait l'accès laconique
donc dans ces cas spécifiques lui n'en
il était déjà nagé la retraite il a pris
sa retraite et il aurait travaillé donc
après les noces ou là
les personnels soignants aujourd'hui pas
vaccinés et tu peux plus travailler dans
tous les cliniques publiques et privées
mais nancy l'obligation jusqu'à a
aujourd'hui les personnels médical
fallait qu'ils soient vaccinés dans les
hôpitaux publics dans les hôpitaux
privés il y avait une certaine tolérance
aux deux milliards par an donc tout le
personnel médical paramédical sont
vaccinés pour soigner les gens les
autres sont suspendus avec
salaire gelé pour celles qui sont pas
publiques
esquissant actuellement travaille pas
dans lequel pas d'argent ces sanctions
qui vont donc jusqu'à la suspension du
salaire est ce que cela peut la pousser
les personnes qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés allez recevoir leurs doses de
vaccin
et j'ai parce que will il faut avoir une
petite minorité qui va à
accepter de certains essais faire
vacciner ces pannes la plupart des gens
mais n'en qui sont pas vaccinés lever le
party faire vacciner donc ce qu'il va
faire et aussi la polémique
c'est qu'elle sait mon là il faudra
qu'ils fassent des tests ils étaient
estimés sur ampli gratuit donc ils
seront payants il a déploré les le moins
cher c'est d'acheter des packs des
vitesses était à 8 heures les tests et
il faut dire aussi que les problèmes
financiers qui est aujourd'hui un partir
d'aujourd'hui on nécessite des fers et
millions de tests partout dans les tests
en est un les problèmes qu'on n'a pas de
personnel pour effectuer la tablette est
donc là aussi il ya un problème des
mises à route on a et on n'a pas vu les
lois mais on n'a pas mis tous les moyens
derrière mais ça où malheureusement
c'est quelque chose que l'on constate
depuis l'apparition de cette épidémie ce
que la politique il est toujours à
contenir le virus s'en mettre toujours
les moyens qu'il faut vous rappeler une
italie à ultrasons et les polémiques de
limaces qu'au départ qui n'est pas
inutile aujourd'hui on oblige avec le
masque donc
et c'est vrai qu'il drague les premiers
ministres en tout cas été formés dans
les tests ils sont à rembourser il
faudra faire le test il n'a pas accepté
une période de taux de tolérance pour
ceux qui n'avaient venu ni la
vaccination
neil et est effectif
on me les ont mis à part la police par
la police le personnel sanitaire mais on
me l'a privé contre les privés mes
parents qu'ils ont une dame des neiges
celui qui doit contrôler la personne
qu'ils soient vaccinés et ça aussi c'est
à ça pousse np en histoire des délations
et des responsabilités finalement les
privés ils ont pas vraiment les moyens
de les contrer les autres ça aussi c'est
une autre polémique qui contrôle qui
font votre témoignage bertoua giovannini
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
chirurgien à 1000